why are all these features missing from
high-end cameras the technology already
exists in our hands in these cameras why
isn't it there in the professional
cameras tinfoil hat time
it is the year 2020 there's not a better
time to be alive if you're an
independent filmmaker but you know what
professional cameras they are still
severely lacking in certain features
that they really should have by this
time because right here in these cheap
cameras are features that these cameras
are missing this camera right here is a
twenty 20 000 camera and if it had some
of the features that this gopro had it
would change my life but it doesn't
right now it's more of a hindrance than
a help and tools here are supposed to
help us create art not get in the way so
let's find out what these problems are
that i hope camera makers solve in 2020
right now both gopros and your phone
have little gyroscopes and
accelerometers built into them so you
can kind of tell how they're moving what
their orientation is and what kind of
g-forces they're experiencing that
information can then be parsed by a
program to give opposite movement to
your footage to cancel out any bumps or
shakes in your footage that's why gopro
shots are so smooth now these days if
you want to stabilize your footage and
you're not shooting on something like a
phone or gopro you have to do it
optically in other words a program has
to follow the points in your picture
track them and then try to undo that
motion so for example if we're getting a
shot of me right now talking and the
camera's all shaky but i'm in the
foreground and i'm moving too it's going
to track me and it's not going to get
the right motion to eliminate the shake
this problem has been solved in consumer
devices like your phones consumer
devices like your gopro and yet here is
a 20 000 camera that doesn't have that
same solution in fact you can go out
there and you can buy a little pack that
you put on a camera that has a little
gyroscope and accelerometer in there and
it will track the motion of that camera
and let you stabilize your footage in
post it's called stead xp now the thing
is there's some caveats one you have to
calibrate this for your lens each time
the second thing is you need to be able
to sync up the data from this little
accelerometer device with your footage
but if this stuff was built in to for
example the black magic that would be
awesome you know i'm already using
blackmagic resolve to edit and manage
all my black magic footage so if they
could build that into the camera just a
little bit of an accelerometer and
gyroscope and some sort of way to
profile your lenses you can have this
all synced up you can just check a box
in your editing program and suddenly
your footage would be stable man when
you're going you're spending as much on
a camera as like a tesla model 3 i kind
of expect some of these things a tesla
can drive itself the red can't even pull
good autofocus
one thing that burns my biscuits is the
lack of good autofocus in modern cameras
here at the studio what we film on are
canon dslrs that have awesome dual pixel
autofocus that reacts very quickly and
effectively they also have touch auto
focus which allows you to select a part
of your screen here and focus on that
particular area it's really cool really
effective i use an a7 iii at home for
photo and video and it has very good
face detection if i actually
highlighting the eyes and knowing the
exact focal plane of within which a face
is on now both the black magic and the
red do have auto focus capabilities the
reds are pretty much unusable they're
very very slow and very difficult to
quickly access we're talking about touch
screens we got this the massive chungus
of the touchscreen here on the red here
i just considering how much processing
powers in this beast and the size of the
touchscreen it seems silly that creating
a good autofocus system is the last
thing on the minds over at red this
thing could run crisis practically but
yet can't focus the black magic while
slightly better only allows you to do
kind of a generalized central spot auto
focus and does get you halfway there but
when it comes to the day-to-day shooting
doesn't really quite do the same thing
it doesn't perform the same way and it's
technology that's out there it's in the
cheapest of cameras everywhere target
best buy a corner market you'll find all
the cameras with decent autofocus but
not here that is one thing that these
cameras really
could benefit from
okay it's 2020 right everyone's been
going on about cameras and all these
expensive cameras and the things that
these cameras should be able to do and i
gotta say
i completely agree it's 20 20. you pay
thousands and thousands of dollars for a
camera why can't a camera give you a
premium
wireless earbud audio experience like
today's sponsor raycon can for a hundred
years people have been trying to figure
out oh what's the next upgrade we can do
with the camera what's the next best
thing that it can give you well guess
what none of them can give you the audio
experience that the raycon e25 earbuds
can they come in a stylish charging
carrying case that you can simply just
slip into your pocket can a red camera
or a black magic camera give you the
audio experience of a premium wireless
earbud that's available at about half
the price of other premium wireless
earbuds no it can't they don't come in
fun colors and patterns like these
earbuds do i mean come on think about it
it's 2020 you spend all this money on
the camera and you can't even get it in
the color that you want
so if you guys are interested in getting
one of the best raycon models yet the
e25 right here has over six hours of
play time it has seamless bluetooth
pairing and it comes in your favorite
colors so click the link in the
description below to get 15
off your purchase this kind of
technology seems seems like it should be
happening now in 2020 if you ask me
all right so quick time out why are all
these features missing from high-end
cameras one of the main ones here is for
example canon they make a huge line of
cameras they make camcorders they make
dslrs they make cinema cameras they make
a whole variety of cameras and if they
were to take all the good video features
and put them into the dslr well you
wouldn't have a reason to buy their
camcorder line anymore so there's a
little bit of internal politics that
prevent these companies from just making
the singular best camera that can do
everything now to be fair a singular
tool that does everything is maybe not
something that exists but that said the
processing power should be there but
it's not so there's a whole internal
politics there as well as the fact that
if you make a camera too good well no
one's going to buy your next one
you know i know it's tinfoil hat time
that we're kind of getting into but it's
true if you put all the features into
your current line you're not going to
have another line to sell to customers
so you have to make sure you keep a
couple imperfections here that you can
solve easily down the line
[Applause]
another feature i desperately need
wireless monitoring hey what's up i'm
using it right now kind of so once again
in the realm of problems that have
already been solved but are for some
reason non-existent in professional
hardware you got wireless monitoring
niko professional hardware has wireless
monitoring you're right the problem is
if you want to do wireless monitoring
these days you have to get a module slap
to the side of the camera figure out a
way to power it get another module slap
it to the side of your monitor figure
out a way to power that and then link
the two together and you finally have a
system but that's a lot of extra
hardware and you know what
gopro god bless their hearts i can
connect my phone to this little camera
and i can see an image on my phone i can
wirelessly monitor from my gopro using
my phone granted there's a lot of
latency and compression but man if this
thing can do it for 400 bucks you sure
would expect that a 20 dollar camera
could do it right it wasn't until
recently that small hd had the genius
idea of packaging a tarot deck and a
monitor together in the same thing to
make one convenient slim little package
and this is one of the best tools i've
ever used this just mounts on your
camera it's a regular monitor has two
little rabbit ears come off the top and
then boom your director your lighting
person anybody can have another monitor
and they can view what's happening
through the camera it is so so so
convenient and yet why aren't they
building things into these guys or even
these guys but the fact they have a
solution for me to wirelessly monitor
with a gopro for 400
makes me wonder why camera manufacturers
don't have a solution for five thousand
six thousand twenty thousand thirty
thousand dollar cameras i can do it with
the small hd system why is it up to a
third party to go out there and put all
these solutions together my phone can do
it my gopro can do it why can't my high
end sit in my camera do it
my personal gripe is that like no
cameras have wireless audio like
natively in the camera and i'm talking
about both like monitoring audio but
also like built-in wireless microphone
audio pretty much everyone i know has
some sort of wireless headphone of some
sort whether it's air pods raycons or
those bone phones and they all hook up
to our phones via bluetooth standard
stuff it's been standard for a while all
you need is bluetooth 4.0 just a regular
run-of-the-mill modern bluetooth chip
hook that into the audio then i can just
use my bluetooth earbuds and monitor the
audio i can know whether or not i'm
getting it without wires dangling
everywhere and having to jack in i don't
know it seems like such a simple thing
and not a single camera that i know of
includes this
for being real you don't have to have
studio quality headphones to monitor
your audio we're talking indie films
we're talking youtube films if you're
running like an actual feature indie
project you probably have your own audio
guy doing their own wireless audio thing
so you don't have to worry about that
this isn't really about that though this
is about just having a camera that you
can monitor audio from with wireless
earbuds come on
so right now i'm just
demonstrating uh the 3d tracking of my
phone how it can
track where it is in 3d space and let me
composite things into the shot so it's
another great example of the fact that
like my phone the combination of its
accelerometers gyroscope abilities and
camera is able to maintain a three
positional awareness of its position in
space
now once again none of the professional
cameras can do that even in like the
highest end alexas and sony's and reds
have no sense of 3d tracking whatsoever
and maybe this is just a byproduct of
the fact that it's a little bit of a
visual effects kind of thing and camera
manufacturers may not be prioritizing
that but imagine if you will that when
you record it through your camera you
also happen to get another file that
records your camera's position in 3d
space so you could literally just be
able to put an object into the scene
anywhere it'd be really really cool it'd
be super useful and especially for us
when we're doing our visual effects to
have real-time 3d tracking from your
camera first and foremost we wouldn't
have to do 3d camera tracking afterwards
when we're doing visual effects which
requires us to track points in the image
so if you have really blurry image or
it's dark
it's really impossible sometimes to get
a 3d track from that but it could just
be built into the footage right from the
get-go the other thing is if you're
filming on a green screen well imagine
being able to film on a green screen and
then instantly eyedrop her out the
background and drop in a real-time 3d
background that already tracks to your
performance you could do
any kind of movie you could do all the
avatars
and you'd have them done way way sooner
than james cameron is getting them done
vr headsets already can do this the 400
rift s has the ability to inside out 3d
tracking that's how it tracks itself and
yet the camera that's the price of a
tesla model 3 can't do it heck the
cameras that are the price of two tesla
model 3s can't do it the technology
already exists in our hands in these
cameras so why isn't it there in the
better cameras
the thing is is that all of these things
we've been talking about already exist
in one form or another and yet they
don't seem to exist in the actual tools
we need them for and there's probably
some good reasons i'm not i'm not
wearing nico's tinfoil hat so it's
there's probably legitimate good reasons
why these things aren't actually
included but at the same time it's like
i feel like most people these days are
only focused on like the hard specs like
what resolution does this camera shoot
what frame rate how many stops of
dynamic range i care about how easy is
this camera to use what are the features
that will make it the best experience
for me getting from shooting something
to uploading it okay and obviously we're
coming at this from the perspective of
being like youtube filmmakers we don't
have giant crews on our sets on film
sets you have like people operating
cameras and a separate focus pooler and
a separate audio manager all kinds of
different roles on set just to operate
one camera but the problem is that if
you are just any person wanting to use
this as like a single person rig you
have some sacrifices and usability and
that's just a little unfortunate
considering that technology is out there
to implement right now i'm hoping that
you know maybe these marketing teams on
on these cameras start trying to drive a
little less for resolution and more for
like how was the best way to use this
camera if i was the only person using it
and honestly these are just a few of the
ideas that we've thought up but i'm
actually very interested in hearing what
you guys think you'd like to see in a
camera in 2020 leave a comment down
below with your ideas if all these
things came together that would be the
camera i'd expect to have my hands in
the year 2020. that would be awesome my
phone can do like all these things will
my professional camera be able to next
year we'll find out